I can't emphasize enough don't fight
Mike Perry you're not gonna beat Mike
Perry even though you might think your
foot works better your jet take all that
out this kid is a dog a dog he breaks
dudes he broke Luke rockhold's teeth
Logan obviously Dylan's done his thing
building up the fight it's obviously you
know across the line a little bit so now
there's all these lawsuits so then Dylan
might have to pull out
all that being said we all want to see
him fight Dylan and then insert Mike
Perry which nobody's talking about but
is a much much different fight this is
this would be worst case scenario for
Logan now Dylan's done his job but if he
doesn't fight
then insert my Perry and it's a
nightmare